now president biden's agenda faces new
hurdles on capitol hill where
progressive democrats may not back down
in a spending standoff house speaker
nancy pelosi wants to pass a huge
infrastructure bill approved by the
senate she says a much larger bill
expanding social programs will have to
wait but that's not sitting well with
progressive lawmakers nancy cordes is at
the white house nancy good morning
good morning nate and negotiations over
all this are at such a critical state
that the president called off a planned
trip to chicago so he could be here in
washington today for the talks and
here's the problem for the president
progressives are holding his feet to the
fire they say until he can secure the
votes for their top priority which is a
huge 3.5 trillion dollar social spending
bill they are not going to vote for his
bipartisan infrastructure bill house
speaker nancy pelosi had been planning
to hold that vote tomorrow but senator
bernie sanders has been pushing his
fellow progressives to vote no and so
here's what it all comes down to today
can the president strike a deal with
these two moderate democratic senators
joe manchin and kirsten cinema they're
the ones who are holding up his 3.5
trillion dollar bill they think it's too
expensive but they haven't said what
they would accept instead white house
aides tell us they are making progress
on all of this but there is no margin
for error without any republican support
they need all 50 democratic senators to
be on board tony
all right nancy thank you very much